hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to tattletale
now I was down in the last episode
because I was rushing very much so and
uh what I'm rushing it usually means
that I'm about to die because I'm making
a lot of noise and I kind of have to
stay here because I don't necessarily
have everything that I need to be able
to do this but unfortunately oh no
fortunately I don't have any needs to
take care of so I just need to be a bit
more patient about it when when when
mama come when Mama comes I just got to
be careful because I don't naturally
make any noise when I'm just by myself
so if I'm by myself I don't necessarily
need to do anything to make sure that I
get away from Mama
I just got it quite see even in the
darkness I don't even need to worry
about anything else making complaints
about the fact that it's dark I just
need to be my own person I don't even
have to freaking move I just have to be
very very very aggressively
understanding about what I'm doing
but everything should be okay if I'm
very quiet isn't that right
mama if that is your real name I think
yeah that's it because mama doesn't
eventually go away which means that I
can then run in here grab what I need
the little mouthy people oh shut up mama
I know mama hates me mom oh I forgot I
forgot you need to be groomed
I forgot you needed to be good I think
she was upstairs but not down here
oh [ __ ] damn I got him I know you need
to be brushed but shut the hold on top
right about now right about now I'm sold
on them whoa that's a big once in our
life I get it
shut up damn it Oh goddamn it goddamn it
goddamn it
Oh what is he good but I don't yes see
Mama's good luck ha shut the [ __ ] up
you're gonna starve in my dirty till the
end of your days yeah
find a friend in the garage and the
garag so then since everything is
hunky-dory I just got to do that make
sure this one gets bad and then
everything should be fine which means
that I got to grab them and then sprint
in and get them fed and then hide for
Mama and then it's as simple as that and
then I'm good to go right probably here
we go
oh oh I think he's in there oh yeah he's
over there eight eight oh now shut the
[ __ ] up let me do my goddamn job oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] that's fine yeah yeah that's how
you do it baby that's how are you doing
I'm very confident about what I'm doing
but I guess how you do it so then you
guys do that okay easy party supplies
pick up tattletale I don't want to do
that I don't I do that wah wah wah
I know I do that supply run find the
cupcakes upstairs I know where they are
they're right upstairs on the they're
right upstairs on the counter I know
that for a fact I've seen them before
not the counter to be uh they're on the
the tape Oh Oh big bond I know so I just
got a gun this and then that's good I
don't know why I gotta bring can fail
along with me just to make my life
harder I know that for a fact
why run find some festive lights you
mean like on the Christmas tree
I don't like oh no she didn't she didn't
see anything okay so I know for a fact I
can wait out mama right here and I'm a
patient man I'm a patient big boy I know
I know I know that she's a calm woman oh
hi hi mama I see you in the window there
I see you spying on me oh oh shut up
don't do anything to ruin my life
oh don't do anything to ruin my life
Oh what's gonna be fine okay and there
you have it Oh like a lot back up and
back ready to go okay and it block as
literally as simple as that right oh
yeah pretty sure
yeah whoo hey run run run got a groove
walk shut up oh hey go go go go go go go
go
hey love you go go go go go okay good
charge you're real quick kostik forever
huh those kinks okay got it
let's going back to my safe spot supply
run Cuba through the kitchen counter I
was right there god damn it
oh oh oh not you don't know that yet I
know this is my safe spot I don't care
if it seems cheap you hey mama
I don't care if it seems cheap to you I
know what I'm doing even though I do
have all my needs met I could make my
way in there but I don't know if the
checkpoint system is still sports as it
was before so I ain't gonna risk [ __ ] on
this one oh boy
why couldn't my mama wake up and help me
my mama just needs to grapple this thing
use her bear mom strength and just [ __ ]
this thing up rivets head off no no no
no no no that's as close as you can get
that's as close as you can [ __ ] get
okay there we go oh god I got another
gun down it's like an even amount of
time when you're waiting for one and an
even amount of time when you're safe
from oh look come these one get longer
getting shut up god damn it I need to
brush him nah [ __ ] it oh I can do it
with them making noise it's just
annoying to me
go back let that will join me on look
like the candle about oh my god their
heads are rolling up in the back of
their eyes oh my god it's pretty
terrifying
oh how be kind rewind I don't have to be
sad
Oh God mom's gonna take me oh oh [ __ ] I
was looking for eggs I wasn't looking
for eggs I was dying trans to make the
lack of those blamin mama stole the kid
can you guys shut up how this is
happening oh oh
I'm not making any noise emember oh no
no no no no no no no no no I'm not
making any noise lady I'm a bear making
the noise not me not me baby I mean you
just go to [ __ ] away I know we're doing
some sort of demonic purge out of your
programming here be just let it happen
lay back relax and oh go to hell okay I
don't think she's gonna go away Oh
Oh can't think I know what I'm closer to
you oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] come here come
to mama better not be I don't want any
event I want a VAT on my conscience ha
[ __ ] goddamn why are you in there how
does any goddamn sense okay I know what
I need to do I need to break the Bob if
men
oh [ __ ] they don't know how you got over
there oh [ __ ] you got it
[Music]
okay I know what I need to do I just
don't know where the eggs are
she ran outside the door okay
it's got to be methodical about it gotta
be nice and methodical in through every
room oh [ __ ] there she is okay that's
fine she can be over there she can be
over there she can be over there she can
be over there that's totally fine
she's got to do this when she's not
around there we go got another one
winner winner baby under winner baby
okay you're over there which is fine if
that's not a ranger this [ __ ] oh she's
gone again okay yeah yeah yeah okay fine
whoo all right um probably send me fear
now yeah I don't know [ __ ] oh god damn
it
all right at least your move okay oh
mama would not wolf up hi okay you know
what I'm very quiet I'm very quiet very
quiet I'm very quiet very quiet very
quiet very quiet very quiet I'm so quiet
[ __ ] now right as I should get maybe
I don't know maybe I should've got off
[ __ ] god this minute huh it was cold
don't you go look okay right there yeah
no no no no no no no don't do that mama
got to get around the corner cool [ __ ]
okay there that where you went before
old dad let me just crack open this one
yeah the last one quick it'll be light
you stay there mama you stay there mama
stay there mama no don't move mama don't
know if I'm honest is Onegin or so you
don't make a goddamn thing
yeah [ __ ] I'm observing
[Music]
okay
yay okay go to bed
Oh how's it that simple huh
oh my free to go well maybe just maybe
ah baby there be some egg around here I
don't know I don't know let's say we're
just really well hidden in the last
round but maybe it's like hey it would
be a little unfair to be hunting for
those things when everything is being
dressed another my moms are Oh egg Hey
okay sure that's how many do I have left
found egg 21 total count 21 22 I'm good
okay I just need to find one more if you
need to find one more and then I'm good
right it's got to be one more round here
that was 21 22 that means that means 22
got to be around here somewhere if I
just look very hard before I go to bed I
just want to make sure that I cover all
my bases before I even touch that bed
then I cover every last square inch of
this place before I even go to bed all
right I'm not seeing it anywhere which
means that it must be if 21 was over
there then 22 must be after I there's a
risk but I've looked absolutely
everywhere like a hundred percent I've
looked everywhere so I'm assuming I
don't know is there gonna be the other
game I don't know [ __ ] ah oh I forgot
there's got to be a Christmas Pig that
that's got to be a thing that happens
again I think yes baby okay I don't have
a flashlight anymore but it's actually
day well that's lovely
Mon yeah I had the wildest few days oh
god it's so beautiful out okay so I got
to open my present but it's 100%
gorgeous out look at all this I'll get
all this oh boy oh [ __ ] I thought I
could open that but I got a lot of base
to cover which means that I got a I got
to be on
look out for my prayers and okay so my
presence does hello hey cupcake wrapper
found act number 22 collected 22 and 22
I did it I think what does that mean did
that do anything for me I don't know
things look so weird in the daytime okay
mama
mom dad mom mom okay well I got all the
eggs I mean that I just do this is it
going to be tattletale who I wanted to
be tattletale oh my god
[Music]
oh my god what are you doing that why is
it doing that that doesn't need to
happen
it could be not that it could be
anything but that are you know what I'm
a big brave boy with big blue pants I'm
a big brave boy I can do this I'm a
brave boy or girl I'm not sure here we
go
I did now open up the box
okay that's that's quick quick that's
much faster Robin septal Hills gift I
don't know if I want to she tattled
he'll tag this is channel tales special
tag given at Birth he must really like
you
cattle sale was born in delightful
decent Illinois on to 2598 he straddled
held handmade with love in our facility
okay baby-talking down bail
[Music]
Wegener gold gold in glass light new
from Wegener electronics the
long-lasting golden flashlight you love
it do I love it wake up your mom whoa
whoa
this is some Waggoner flashlight mom
[Music]
that why is that a thing that needs to
be done I don't think this is
appropriate wrong okay here we go
[Music]
thank you he's bigger than you what this
what was that oh come on what oh man
that would have made my life a lot
easier if I had a [ __ ] level select
Oh God
okay so I'm gonna look up about the
secret ending because I have all of the
eggs I just don't know what else to do
okay so I get it now the good ending was
what we got we didn't die on Christmas
Day that was the good ending I just
didn't even know because I hadn't even
seen the bad ending so wouldn't we open
that box if you get all the eggs or if
you don't get all the eggs and you open
that box the box is empty there is no
tattle-tale in there there's only mama
and mama kills you dead but anyway that
is tattletale and that is [ __ ] horror
fun really well done I gotta say really
well done with what they did it became a
little easy to gain the mechanics after
a while but even so the the arc that
they crafted and the build-up that they
had for the scares was incredible I
love did a lot it really built up a lot
because it told you it dropped you hints
and red herrings from the get-go before
the actual danger was there all while
training you in what you were supposed
to do it's a really well done like from
a game design standpoint that's really
well done and from a horror standpoint I
was really scared so either way thank
you everybody so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed this very much let me
know down in the comments below what you
think and if there are any other secrets
that I have missed so that you can help
your fellow gamer out thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]